what's up guys so Hollywood is remaking
another classic movie 1980s action
powerhouse Robocop our good friend Nick
Mundy wants to talk to the makers of the
new Robocop elite okay so here's the
thing okay like okay you see my slow it
one sec what do you say we watch the new
Robocop trailer together we have - yes
very futuristic are there mountains in
Detroit we're gonna put a man inside a
machine you need to speak to your son II
know you don't
he doesn't need a family he's a ping
robot Caroline you're coming with me
there you have it you had some specific
thoughts and what they could do to make
it better I've come up with like a list
of like things that like might improve
on what I think might just be an utter
utter piece of garbage all right so the
first thing make it rated-r there's a
specific reason why Robocop needs to be
rated on remember back when we were kids
in 1987 and our parents thought it would
be like hey would it be fun if we took
the kids to see the silly cyborg cop
movie that might be a lot of fun a robot
Polly yeah man stay out of trouble
they didn't know that they were taking
us to one of the most violent sadistic
brutal action movies of all time parents
didn't know things back then my dad
smoked two packs a day right next to my
crib our parents were probably smoking
in the theater while we were watching
officer Murphy get murdered into
hamburger by Clarence Boddicker and his
really cool friends before us on that
scene uh hey I enjoyed childhood
innocence it was like a Robocop Bar
Mitzvah yes that's when we became men
and that's why I'm the guy you see
before you I turned out fine right it
turned out great Nick thank you
this movie is going to raise a
generation of just children you want it
to be a hard our next cut samuel
l.jackson out of the movie why he's
bored out of his mind he's giving Bruce
Willis and Harrison Ford a run for their
money as the guys who show up in as many
movies as possible reading got monthly
why do you mean samuel l.jackson in this
movie you have Michael Keaton he does
one movie every 15 years and we're lucky
to see it what about a little side order
of Gary Oldman we don't need any other
actors in the movie you just get the
spear of a cop and Keaton and they could
just talk I would watch that movie I
take old men over Keaton you
real squibs I told them to do this with
die hard and they didn't think listen
listen to me use real squibs for going
out there squibs is when the blood pops
out of your chest we're getting shot in
an 80s action movie and nowadays they
use digital squids watch one of the
Expendables if you want to see what a
digital squib looks like and how much it
sucks this movie if it wants to pay
tribute to one aspect of the original it
needs to be switched again are you pro
or con squibs don't put a message in
robocop one of the reasons why Robocop
was awesome was because Paul Verhoeven
did this perfect combination of like
satirizing like violence and corporate
greed and capitalism series 7 sports
heart by Jensen extended warranties
financing qualifies for health tax
credit and remember we care unless the
new movie is trying to satirize the
studio remakes by making a fee studio
remake don't put a message in the movie
without the message it's just gonna be a
generic action movie I would rather have
it be a generic action movie then try to
be a generic action movie with some like
Ramdan message yeah Ezra what do you got
next Nick no humanity the thing about
the first Robocop was he had no humanity
left Murphy had a wife and son what
happened to them he had his skin
plastered over metal but then he slowly
got it back and that was like the
journey
nice shooting son what's your name
Murphy but this new Robocop is just like
hey Dad your metal that's weird but
there is a scene in the trailer where
Robocop's like talking to his son like
I'm you're a robot dad I know no I can't
wait for the second act baseball montage
where he's teaching this kid how to
throw the ball and he throws it way too
hard and then throws it through a brick
wall and they're like oh whoops that's
not gonna happen
that will probably happen there's
nothing in the trailer that says that
that won't happen
great so Nick you're a monster lastly
don't call the movie Robocop
this movie was called something else I
would be in to seeing it police cyborg
yeah totally into that Android five-oh
into it officer droid first one in line
digital detective would love it I'd be
into it the problem is it's ripping off
and sucking the bone marrow of one of my
favorite movies hey let's make Total
Recall
and die hard 5 and then just can ruin
everything that I love and it's just
horse you know it's the worst part is I
want this movie to be good don't make me
look right I'm asking idiot ok I want
this movie to be good I'm not the good
guy I'm the guy bitching about movies on
the Internet
you're making the movie make it great
I'd buy that for a dollar did you agree
with Nick Mundy did you disagree with
him and by the way what do you think is
the worst remake of all time total Rico
House badly tell us what the worst
remake was and why in the comment
section below
best answer gets $25 gift card from Best
Buy
brought to you by cinnamon al from Best
Buy also we gave a call to action at the
beginning of the summer tell us what's
the top 10 summer box-office movies are
going to be why do you responded finally
we have a winner
Kevin Navarro correctly picked eight out
of ten summer box-office champions and
he is our champion and we are sending
him as we promised to screen junkies
t-shirts werewolves give one to your mom
put one on your dog and send us a
picture I want to thank my good friend
Nick Mundy sir quite all right love
having you here I'm Hal Rudnick thanks
for watching bye bye flash back to our
hero Rick falling into a coma after
being shot by armed robbers in that coma
Rick just misses the dead becoming
reanimated and his wife and kid
replacing him with his best friend I
thought it was bad when I overslept and
just got a parking ticket on street
cleaning day